to all of you watching this episode of
notch indeed want to give you a quick
caveat like last week we had a hard
drive failure and lost some of our
footage and so the first half of this
episode you won't see my camera angle at
all but it'll pop in in the second half
just want to give you guys a heads up
that unfortunately gonna have to look at
how beautiful lyric is for the first
half of this episode which what a shame
for you guys enjoy to turn your great
idea into a reality with Squarespace
Squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project whether
you're showcasing your work or selling
products of any kind with beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything you can easily make
a beautiful website all on your own but
if you do get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help so head to squarespace.com slash
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use offer code grace to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain welcome to another
episode of not too deep I'm very excited
because this episode we have the lovely
and the funny the insanely talented
lyric Lewis with us she's on ap bio
she's been on baskets she's a member of
the main company at The Groundlings
she loves Harry Potter and Jurassic Park
so much I had no idea she is Slytherin
though but she's one of the good ones
we'll hear all about it on this episode
of not too deep with lyric Lewis
lirik thank you so much for being here
thank you for having no course no you
were just saying that you're about to go
back into the second season of ap bio
yes and you guys have been off for how
long almost a year almost a year yeah so
I mean it's in school terms you get off
for summer break but this must have been
adult terms felt like the longest summer
break of your life oh it was they left
much too much time to get into trouble
yeah as teachers normally do on summer
break but you were saying you and your
co-stars are actual friends in real life
and you hang out in real life
yes it's Mary and Jean yes yeah okay and
so you they knew each other before yes
but you went into casting kind of blind
not knowing them at all mm-hmm but then
I mean chemistry is chemistry and it's
undeniable when it happened and we fell
in love with each other that cuz it
could go either way so that's a great
way yeah we could have been like I hate
you and hate you no we like right away
clicked and just like it fell into each
other very easily and like yeah we're
all improvisers so we all right away but
it's improvising with each other and
like but not trying to one-up each other
and not sort of yes yeah China out funny
because we're like with three funny
women right and it's rare enough to see
it on television anyway oh no that must
have been the coolest part about working
together is they won you get to be
authentically very funny women and to
you get to be funny women in this kind
of role that I think is really fun to
explore it must be fun to play a teacher
that gets to be ridiculous yes because I
mean is it weird at all do you get like
flashbacks at all to any teachers that
you had growing up you know what no I
feel like stuff to me is like the
teacher that I feel like I wish that I
had like Steph is like very chill and
like she has a dating life or a very sad
one but she did you know and she like is
stylish and I feel like she you know
also I feel like is a nod to I feel like
real teachers that I'm like they're hot
blooded red-blooded individuals and they
have lives and they are also fashionable
and like to have fun right they also
enjoy teaching and I think that's the
fun part about Steph is that she loves
teaching she loves her school she loves
the principal and the kids and I
she has fun there versus it being like
this thing that she has to do yeah so
that's what I think is really fun to
play her no I mean it's yeah I think you
definitely play a character of a teacher
that I wish that I had that had
confidence that had enthusiasm that had
just like a positive aura around them
even in like a bleak small town yeah
okay so talk to me about Groundlings is
where you came up through right yes okay
I went to the people's Improv Theater in
New York so I have no real knowledge of
The Groundlings how was that experience
for you and how did you even get started
there so how I got started was I feel
like the classic like geek story so I
went to Syracuse to have a BFA in
theatre for a York useless I was like
I'm gonna be an actor
because I need a degree to do it and
they're like no girl no one cares what
your GPA was invoice first but I was
like I'm really good at Shakespeare no
one cares so I did that but while I was
at Syracuse I'd always been kind of
funny as a kid and like I feel like
naturally just like enjoyed making
people laugh while I was there and like
we would watch scary movie the first one
every weekend like why we weren't like
out in the streets who knows maybe
probably was too cold yeah Syracuse very
beautiful but freezing ABB's freezing
one's balls off yeah cuz you grew up in
New Orleans right I'm from New Jersey
and I went to school in northern New
Jersey so like not far from Syracuse but
yeah you have full winter you have to
dig your car yes so like we would watch
a great movie every weekend and like for
some reason like I've grown up watching
like SNL and in living color and all
these sketches and I always was like oh
I'd love to just you know make people
you know laugh and just be funny and
Regina Hall did it for me and scary
movie where I feel like she was one of
them and even though I had seen sketch
yeah I feel like on film she was one of
the I don't know why I just remembered
this stuck out to me so much I think I
was the was like the impressionable
phase but I was like oh she's funny with
like no vanity but so funny and after
that I was like oh girl that's what
we're doing it
yes and so um all of the training in
Syracuse is like very like theatrical
like it's like stage yeah they may have
changed the curriculum now but then I
mean we learned how to like do stage
combat and like cuz I would imagine
you're so close to New York that that's
the like logical next step is like a
drive right yeah and so I just started
doing research as I was like oh I want a
funny comedic career like I was like I
want to be like a funny woman
it wasn't the trend yet women country
Kristen Wiig and bridesmaids and
everything but I started researching
people that I dug and like Jennifer
Coolidge is someone that I love yeah and
I just heard character stuff like I'm
like I want to be that like I don't care
what I look like I want people to quote
me on the street yeah and so her and
like Cheri Oteri and even like Kim
Wayans and like people like that I feel
like really funny and with the exception
of Kim Sheree Molly Shannon Jennifer
Coolidge they all were Groundlings and
so okay then I was like okay like I need
to get into this and like Cheryl Hines
like her like all of them so I like did
my research and I'm like okay Coolidge
is a groundling and Oteri is a
groundling and even welfare I'm like
okay he was a ground man Chris Kattan
wasn't so I like and I'm like who are
these people and how can i I need to do
this training so after I graduated I
literally just like my mom lives in
Minnesota now which is also very random
cuz we couldn't get enough of the Kobach
please barry manilow me but i went to
junior high in high school in Minnesota
okay
yes girl interested you love cheese
curds if anyone has a great current
recipe I love a good curd so um I went
back to Minnesota and I drove from
Minnesota out to LA and I was just like
I'm gonna go to this place called The
Groundlings and like with everything so
in my car like auditioned like you were
the cliche and start at the pro got in
and I was like great I was just and like
had no nothing of like the main
companies Sunday company like I just was
like I just want to do as much classes
as I can do so I can kind of be as good
as these people that I think are
really funny and that was it that's
awesome now how long have you been there
um total like I'm still I'm in the main
company now so I've been in the main
company for like three years but the
program took maybe like six or seven
years to get through
that's so not so basically another like
master's program yeah you went through I
counted as my graduate school yeah
that's so nice but you still perform
regularly yes yeah that must be so fun I
saw that you just had David Tennant in
the show with you what was that like he
was I mean and granted like an eye and I
feel like it please no one come for me
preface is something with that do not
come for me because I granted like I
know the Doctor Who in Mike Rogers but
like I was like that Potter fan and so I
was just saying and I did test into how
Slytherin so because I mean from jessica
jones i kilgrave gave me my life and put
it back in my body yeah that was so
insane it was amazing and so just from
that like and I had no idea he was doing
that show and so you didn't know but I
already knew I was doing it then I saw
the poster and I was like oh my god he
is the nicest most giving it like I mean
just so sweet and it's just like down to
play and do whatever I mean he was so
not like oh that's so fun I mean there
must have been pants [ __ ] ly nervous
energy beforehand but eyes you know like
and he was nervous
nice to see when someone is at such a
level in your brain that they're like
vulnerable in some way yeah yes
something that I'm a huge fan of is dr.
Alan Grant yeah this is your dog yeah
and he happy belated birthday he just
turned 2 yes he did um how how did he
get this name the fun thing about me is
that I've like top 5 movies I don't know
what the other 5 4 are
Jurassic Park is in that I feel like I
was this is another geek answer that
like I feel like you know there's films
are like directors like it made me want
to direct yeah yeah and I as a kid I was
always into science and I still am but
like science and like true-crime like
like weird science he stuff but I like
loved dinosaurs as a kid so when that
came out I feel like because it looked
so good yeah
shout out to feel tippet and Stan
Winston for bringing the animatronic
dinosaurs the puppetry to life but it
looked so good I think I was young
enough that I was like I wanted my
career to be next to them that I'm like
I know they don't exist but it looks
amazing yeah yeah and they just like did
it for me so like dr. Alan Grant name
came from uh Sam Neal's character dr.
Alan Grant I always said if I have a
girl her name would be dr. Ellie Sattler
and if there's a third dog dr. Ian
Malcolm just with his body splayed
incredible and he's such a total cutie
by the way he's he's great and I feel
like he owns it like where did you get
him from oh we found be like found this
little family and burping
it was like we had some puppies and so
we went to go meet him and like he was
the smallest one and like his sisters
were like running amok and we were like
we will have him and then we named him
dr. grant and I feel like he owns his
name where he's like kind of grouchy
like dr. grant was in the movie but like
we'll play when he wants to yeah doesn't
really want to like see the children
will be around the children but then
he'll get to like the children later
that's incredible
has he been to set is he a set dog he
has not been yet okay CBS is trying to
hit on my life away with this for so
long the one day Alan grants go roll
through I'll be like oh like I didn't
see the sign yeah exactly
I only asked for forgiveness don't beg
for permission there you go that's what
I've heard I don't necessarily live my
life by that but working towards that
we're in a season two now I'm like I can
yeah yeah Alan okay how is the feedback
been for you from season one
like his family watched it have friends
watched it yes you know it's the thing
that's nice about is that I love that I
have friends like large I'm sure there's
some friends that are so like we've
gotta tell Derek nice things but by
large feel like they're very honest and
like the honest feedback has been like
yo this show is like super smart and
dark and funny yeah they're like it's on
like then like NBC but like it goes
there I think people were surprised that
yeah cuz it's so the colors are so
bright it looks like a sitcom you know
it looks like it should be this like
Glee esque kind of like tie it up with a
sweet bow show and then you realize like
oh this is very dark yeah and so that's
fun it's been great which makes me happy
cuz I'm like yes now everyone can be
just as excited about it as I am yeah do
you know do you have any indication or
have you been told anything about your
character in the upcoming season I don't
I just know she has more knee-high boots
coming have you gotten to keep any of
your wardrobe oh my god no it's like in
the trailer so like I'm sure if I really
was like please let me wear these
Stewart Wiseman is out in the street
maybe but but I mean her stuff like I
just came from a fitting today and so
her stuff for season 2 is super cute we
got some bright colors happening we've
got some fall codes all right and we've
got like I said lots of knee-highs oh
that's so fun do you guys get to
improvise it on set or do they try to
keep it kind of like to the script oh
yes yeah and I think because Mike
O'Brien you know it comes from second
city right and you're Patton I'll go
with you and stuff on a Jean and Mary
are also second city Chicago and so with
just even the three of us together like
we'll do like a clean take or to that
Mike will be like okay let's get it but
then like after that he's like alright
just have fun and so we just keep it
going and just and my Staten is there
and like well Patton when he is there he
will like listen and if you've said
something funny in between and take
he'll go oh and don't forget you said
that because like that was really funny
and you'll be like thanks Patton because
I was flying out of my ass that is there
to be like no girl remember the funny
stuff that you
yes great and even Glenn like she loves
to improvise with us too so it's yeah
there's definitely a big just kind of
see what we want to say vibe that has
such a great energy on set - that makes
it much more of a safe space yeah you
can feel like a big production I'm sure
so like it can be nervous energy
sometimes if it's not just like let's
just have fun
yeah and Mike definitely sets the tone
and set the tone with that from the
beginning that's great that I think he
was just like let's like make this fun
yeah and like if we're having fun it'll
come through on camera
mm-hmm and then people will enjoy
watching it and yeah I want to watch it
for sure okay let me talk to you about
your passion which I believe is true
crimes podcasts from what I've gathered
I've been super into a serial is the
only one that I have not we were just
talking about this before you got here
the one I haven't delved into yet at all
at all I don't know why I think it's
just been like around so I feel like my
wave has passed on like getting into it
but now season 3 is out girl and no are
you into have you been listening yes of
course three but you got to go back now
because that case mm-hmm the first one
season one we all go it has a resurgence
yes there were things happening with
Adnan Syed as oh yes so like it is never
too late now if anything now would be
the time cuz now there's like fresh
stuff to read yes oh yes yeah I got big
into dirty Jon that was insane and I
also like Google Image Search like what
all these people look like he - I feel
really weird I did that and then I was
like oh and but I did like halfway into
the series I was like I shouldn't have
done this because now I'm picturing
these people like I'm picturing his like
dirty mirror selfie that he takes
themselves also dr. death oh I haven't
listened to that the same people that
did dirty job dr. death is in say oh
what's that one about oh my god it's
about this neurosurgeon Christopher
Dench Christopher because you know what
you did the neurosurgeon that like
Boches his surgeons but like to the
point of like removing vertebrae's from
people but then sewing them back up and
being
whatever I did the best that I could do
and it's like Oh or just be a surgeon
and about like the Board of Health like
in Texas not stepping in and like
removing his license and being like well
we'll just refer him to another hospital
what that's okay it's only six parts
okay just release the seven to give us
an update oh main thing is six parts in
and out okay any other recommendations
any other great love I mean some of them
are dark like I or hit me with love
sward and scale sward and Swart
sward and scale but that one is dark I
don't know that one either
it's the nitty gritty but it's also so
good okay so that's another wandering
one who else true-crime obsessed yeah
this one's like a funny one okay like
these two what is I think we need we're
jingles on the show but they literally
like watch all these they they do do
like the staircase they did season one
they did like the Galapagos affair they
do like all these true-crime things but
like their banter is just so funny so it
will be something like crazy but then
they make it light-hearted they do
they're so funny that it's light heart
and also true crime junkie okay that one
is also a good you just gave me my
entire like next month of my there I
appreciate it
okay what are you watching right now do
you watch lot of TV when you're not
listening to true crimes because it's
weird because I feel like I'm one of
those people first I feel like I'm
overwhelmed like there's so much cocaine
streaming Netflix and Hulu and Amazon
and regular Douglas megalith TV where
like I feel like I watch the same things
over and over now cuz I'm like I'm
overwhelmed yes - wait what do you watch
I do watch out homicide hunting so we
have a genre that you lieutenant Joe
Kenda I don't even know if it's on air
anymore like I solve these crimes
but I thought I was just watching I was
just watching Castle Rock okay which is
like the Stephen King anthology wine
okay I need to rewatch like you know
those shows that you watched and you're
like did I pick what happened
it had no attention I like reality a lot
to like oh me too of The Real Housewives
of Atlanta NeNe Leakes if she ever was
in the same room as me I would lose my
goddamn eye I mean like I love her yeah
I love her I left handy like I love them
all
kandi is the most impressive
businesswoman insane and the fact that
she's not married to what was a PA on
the show blows my mind I mean
shout out to Todd did you watch the
xscape like a little miniseries yeah I
did not so I need to go back how was
that it was okay they clearly were
testing a miniseries to see if there's
anything there and then she like pulled
out of like the actual tour that they
were doing I don't know if she did the
tour but it was one long kind of drama
drawn out for four or five episodes
whatever it was I don't need this yeah I
mean yeah Kandi's a businesswoman though
it's like look she got another
miniseries that coin which is in this
bag great okay we're gonna take a quick
break and when we get back we'll
probably talk about more reality TV
because it's just opened the floodgates
that you guys oh no I love talking about
so much we'll be right back with more
not too deep and surprise surprise
guess who's supporting this episode of
not too deep it is drum roll Squarespace
turn your dream into a reality with
Squarespace there are buddies they've
been sponsoring this show for a long
time you guys know this fight now but if
you don't you got to know that
Squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project whether
you're looking to start a new business
showcase your work published content
sell products and more Squarespace is
the tool for you with beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks
you can easily make a beautiful website
all by yourself
and they have a powerful ecommerce
functionality which lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever I'm buying domains
as simple and you'll get the help you
need with their 24/7 award-winning
customer support
Squarespace empowers millions of people
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas into something real and I am
one of those I don't know if I'm more of
a restaurant or a gym you're right and I
do have many Squarespace websites
because it's so easy to use so check
them out and while you're at it go to
Squarespace calm slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain at squarespace.com slash grace
offer code grace hey guys instead of
buying new things
head to Poshmark to shop from millions
of closets across America listen to this
Poshmark is the easiest way to buy and
sell fashion items you download the free
Poshmark app to shop from tons of brands
across women's kids and men's you won't
believe the deals you'll find like Louie
Vuitton bags for $300 that's nuts
that's crazy and shipping is super fast
and easy for both the seller and buyer
and is handled all through the Poshmark
app when you see something that you want
simply make the seller an offer and you
can get the item that works at a price
for you need to clean out your closet
listing on Poshmark
is easy upload pictures of your stuff to
the app set a price and then ship to the
lucky buyer no more waiting in line at
your local thrift store just to leave
empty-handed this is something I do I'm
a full like a spring cleaning kind of
person but kind of like every three
months sure so I always wonder I mean I
drop my clothes off for a donation but
this is another alternative way to you
know clean out your closet yeah you can
sell stuff and you can buy cool stuff I
mean there are just as many people out
there that you know bought that you know
Gucci sweater they only wore one you
know now you can kind of get a good
discount on it yeah today you can get
five dollars off your first purchase
when you enter the invite code not too
deep when you sign up
just download the Poshmark app sign up
and enter the code not too deep all one
word for five dollars off your first
would you ever be on a reality
television show you know what I thought
about yeah I don't know like I feel like
like if I could be like a Housewives of
Atlanta like I think that I would want
to do it like that where all I want to
do is go and eat small plates
[Music]
small plates and half glasses of Pinot
Noir and like champagne and just do that
and like and then plan an ultimate like
friend vacation that's gonna go awry and
just you know cuz I feel like I mean I
don't think like I'm nothing not into
drama but I say what I feel like and
what I want yeah so I feel like I'd be
juicy enough to be on the show where I'd
be like no you did say that
yeah wait who was the woman that was on
roses of Atlanta that was from facts of
life Oh Kim field yeah Kim fields I feel
like she was they wanted her to be juicy
and she's just a decent person but she
was like I have children yeah they're
not gonna argue with you where I'm they
were like all right so we don't have
anything with this woman where catch me
on the right time of day I might be like
don't actually let me pull up these
receipts for you you recently went to
the Beyonce jay-z concert I did how was
that it was so fun first of all I just
want to say when I say that when they
were onstage together and he was looking
at her like she was in snack dinner
biscuit on the side like I was like I
think everyone was just like to see them
in person I'm like oh my god and the way
she looked it was so fun and you're like
incredible together but I was just like
oh you can feel the love which I felt
was like the way they would just look at
each other I was like oh my god they
really and she's incredible like I'd
never seen her in person and when I say
a performer like I would have been I was
out of breath watching her like the
intro like I was like whoa gasps and I
mean she's in boots heels hmm yeah so it
was awesome that much I mean I feel like
Beyonce concert like I
only I went to the VMAs a couple years
ago and saw her do like a 12 to 15
minute like a bridge version of lemonade
and it was like an out-of-body
experience I can't imagine an entire
concert I mean I'm with Jase he whiffed
it it was truly awesome okay what is
your relationship with social media my
relationship is like I feel like it's
unloved hate
yeah I love hate I think that see a par
for the course do you have like a
favorite that you look at or that you
post to like Twitter Instagram snapchat
Instagram yeah like I almost like forget
about Twitter like and thank God my
Twitter is connected to my Instagram
people know that I'm alive you're alive
like and even Facebook like I feel like
I don't really think about that where I
think Instagram something is still fun
enough about that I'm like oh it's just
pictures and it's like right my day even
though now you know it's like lyric you
can't just be pictures of like your foot
[Laughter]
I have like a social media presence and
like make it like curated yes and
everywhere because like and I think that
I I'm not like I'm too old for social
media but I feel like when it started
like all of them were just like just
something fun I do yeah we're now it's
this machine where it's like oh I gotta
think of something clever to say we're
like in most things I'm like oh I'm just
not thinking of it enough where I'm in
front of very cool visually appealing
places that I'll go home and be like oh
wait I was just at the Eiffel Tower and
I didn't get a picture now I'm at my
balcony dang well I'll take another
picture of another can of Lacroix do you
have anyone that you love following
that's like the person you're either
like hate following or like genuinely
love following like I love following
Oprah on Instagram because she posts
like kind of ridiculous but like
well-meaning things it's a lot of you
know the new branding of Weight Watchers
how it's changed but it's really fun I
love following Will Smith
oh I don't follow him he like just I
don't not that long ago and like but
he's so funny and like it's just him
being goofy with his kids and like
aggravating Jada and like they're both
still so cute together but his is one
that he does still that inspirational
Will Smith
Huell coming alright y'all the worried
about the wrong thing this is what life
is but like something he's so
charismatic that she like I could watch
you talk all day yeah and it must be
nice because you get that uh like
authentic side of him yeah still
charming Will Smith it's like oh but you
are no one's holding your phone taking
videos of ya and producing it for you
yes so he's a fun one he's a good one
okay I have to like remember that do you
have a social media like pet peeve oh I
can in like I get it but I don't okay
but like when and I have friends who
like I'm like okay after xx selfie in
the same position of yourself like we
know what you look like or just caption
it like just wanted another picture of
myself I can say like the same pose just
a different shirt but being like you
know Wednesday's are magic when it's not
and it's like use the same picture two
days ago
Monday's being like awesome I did like I
don't know why and I'm like or do it
artist like mm-hmm
but some people it's literally the same
yeah angle yeah it's very frustrating I
have to like give myself space from that
kind of thing every now and then what's
been like your best or most unique
filming experience cuz you run baskets
which I love so much and I think Louie
Anderson is one of the greatest female
characters on TV weird and crazy to say
but like what was that experience like
amazing I mean him and Zach are both so
awesome and just giving but Louie has
dislike and I mean he's done it for so
long that he almost had this like sweet
fatherly type of big brother E presence
on that a me and honey for the girl who
plays my sister like all day cuz a lot
of all of our scenes I think are with
him and like all day he was like would
you like a smooth deer would you like
like just taking care of us and like
asking about our careers and giving tips
and being like this is what I archery
which is so nurturing they're like I
didn't necessarily expect that from him
right yeah it's amazing and like so that
I will say as one of the most unique
because in between takes he's checking
in
where you ladies doing you guys need
need like just oh so sweet to hear make
sure we had almond milk smoothie
basically he's just in character the
whole time just be nice is that's so fun
have you had any I'd love to ask people
that you know are working in the
industry about like their worst
auditioning experience if there's
anything that sticks out to you
mmm-hmm there is one okay there's when I
won't name the project sure I knew right
away when I got the sides I was like oh
I don't know if this is for me but it's
with this casting director and she's
kind of big so I won't anymore either
but I moved for a period piece I will
say that okay period piece and I am it
was just weird cuz like I was reacting
to a lot of emotional things and I like
jumping at things being thrown at me but
I thought I was reacting and then out of
nowhere just ended she threw a box of
Kleenex at me and I was like and she was
like that was great good reaction Thanks
and I was like she threw an actual box
and I was like oh I guess it didn't hurt
but there was no warning before you
started your audition they're like we're
gonna throw actual things no and I was
like ma'am and then she was also like oh
we went to Syracuse great oh great no
wonder you can cry on command and I was
like oh I'm sorry I didn't ask to come
today
wow really just shooting on you from the
top from the top and I was like is this
weird tough love or should I actually
leave right now
it looks so weird but then I was just
like but then like I guess she's kind of
tough like that in general so I was okay
great she didn't hate me from my
inception yeah yeah yeah I know it's
such an insane process do you do
anything give any rituals they do or any
like calming exercises when you go in
for auditions or anything you know I
listen to like I always just listen to
like Barre amped up like super just like
pumped up nothing like that's my like
very loud what am I even though this is
not pumped up one of my favorites
listened to is the thong song degree
from Syracuse and this is your acting
it gets you like this very like you like
it Lewis and after you do it a little
song song dance by yourself in the car
you're ready to for whatever Oh God I
mean you should teach a workshop I mean
that is a great takeaway like Thank You
Cisco for making the thong song it
really shaped their generation
it really did I don't think I ever wore
a thong before then after that girls
were like we have to wear the hall I
remember watching the whole like MTV
behind the music video of that the
making of the music and the fact that it
was like glow-in-the-dark oh my god
they're glow-in-the-dark bathing suits
Oh incredible oh my god I got my first
doll from Claire's boutique don't worry
about shout out the Clio super why they
so long I have my ears pierced at
Claire's
I didn't know the Mall of America merica
store they sold thongs Oh me and my
friend bought metallic fatigue songs for
house party metallic don't forget that
oh my god I mean if you're gonna go into
the song world incredible Wow
you told me it so you moved from New
Orleans to Minneapolis yeah st. Paul st.
Paul when you were 12
yes which like you said is the worst age
to move a child anywhere let alone from
a very cool town to what I can imagine
is less cool yeah I mean it's like for
family yeah it's it's cold in New
Orleans is not right rolling in Thunder
snow yeah and then well so I've been to
the Mall of America a couple times as an
adult it's very fun and I still feel
like I've only seen 25% of it yeah I
mean I still love them of America it's
so funny now because I feel like when I
first moved from New Orleans I kind of
course I was like an opposition yeah of
Minnesota as a state but now of course
like I'm like I love it like I like it
has this wholesome vibe but I'm like I
got it I'm with you I'm with on Annie's
cookies yes I will purchase a tub but
the mall I mean I think
at the Mall of America made me like have
a fondness for just malls for the
structure that's somewhere but not like
the shops - I can like like I love
walking around the mall and like window
shopping and there's so much at the Mall
of America did you work there ever I did
I used to work at Express in the mall
you America yes we were I think a two
million dollar store or a hundred
million one of those extremes like I
know was we were an eighth store at the
Mall of America don't worry about us I
was a fashion expert amazing I had
expressed at the Mall of America at MOA
oh my god Express was like a little
above my shopping budget when I was in
high school but that's like all the
girls that were like upper middle class
used to wear Express all the time yeah
it was something I idolized so that's
very cool to me you get an employee
discount oh yes I did I got a nice 40%
off at a spread
that's amazing do you go back to the
Mall of America when you go home yes
really I was just there for my sister's
wedding and made a trip to the mall with
my nieces and nephews and my grandma was
living with two Legoland bought him of
course
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom what I
would consider a superfan of Jurassic
Park what did you think of the most
recent one you know what fallen Kingdom
and fallen you know world and world
fallen Kingdom I think that they're fun
yeah I like I enjoy them I feel like no
one will ever be one like none of them
will ever be one yeah and I dare Chris
Pratt to argue with me about it you know
I feel like you just can't top it and
like one had very little CGI just like
I'm a fan of like seeing it look real
and yeah but I think world and fallen
Kingdom are both super fun and I think
that and I love it because my nephew is
so little and like Park is still very
scary for him to watch but he can like
handle world and falling Kingdom so I'm
like me because he loves dinosaurs -
thank you so I'm like it me and him can
watch these together and like that's how
I assure him in and I slap Park on
that's me yeah I mean you're an educator
through and through
I used to work at the Science Museum of
Minnesota so really I was a counselor
and a camp director for there like
summer programs oh that because was that
the initiation was that you loved
Jurassic park's then I like got into and
like of course it's like those real
science inside of it like the bones but
then we also did like Harry Potter camps
we went into the science behind Harry
Potter well we like made like you know
all these potions and stuff they played
Quidditch we celebrated his birthday
Harry Potter is a cancer oh very
emotional young man okay
if you could be cast in let's say they
made more Harry Potter's or and more
Jurassic world's what would you put
yourself in us oh so it was Jurassic
world now I'm pitching this directed
your time stamping you heard it here
first the idea um that I want to come
back as samuel l.jackson 'he's daughter
from the first movie and i want to be
like ah I want to be like y'all let
these velociraptors eat my dad
we only got a lone cigarette mailed back
to us in the state okay and that was it
maybe the arm goes arm in the cigarette
that's all we got cuz they couldn't even
find no more head buddy something like
that at least y'all can do is let me get
up here with these dinosaurs and find
out who killed my dad I would come back
I would also come back against whoo
cuz wound oh he has something to do with
it so BD wrong I'm coming for you as
well and so that's what that's what
would be my role in Jurassic world is
Jackson's daughter I think that's great
and I was fight to see that he just ran
away because people love his character
oh I would have my own tag line I can't
hold on to your books it might be like
or not
[Laughter]
in the merge cells itself so funny so
that and then if it was then Potter huh
you know I don't I don't know I feel
like I would want to be a fun fun
teacher oh yeah I'd be a fun teacher I
feel like I would like to do I would
imagine they would do like I would like
to do like horoscopes like the
horoscopes and reading of the stars
class and just being like now re-pour
your cancer means that you're very deep
and you should watch out for trouble I
love that and then like we don't know
how she got into this school we don't
know she's not actually on the roster as
a teacher she's not she's not from can't
place it we can't please I also would
love that I really can see this in your
future and hope this happens for you
please tell Warner Brothers that I'm
available
Warner Brothers both the brothers
Universal for Jurassic let me know
they're they listen to our podcast on a
weekly basis know we're gonna take
another quick break when we get back we
have Internet questions for you which
are always the most fun so we'll be
right back with more not too deep look
it's tough to make new friends as an
adult I'll be the first to say it yep
and I mean how are you supposed to seek
out meaningful platonic relationships as
an adult when you spend most of your
time behind a desk at a computer you
know sequestered in the silence of your
own home well guess what that's where
Bumble BFF comes in hey have you heard
of it while bumble begin is a women
first dating app it now includes a
friend finding mode called bumble bee FF
find a kindred spirit to join you at
that yoga workshop or a fellow 90s
sitcom fanatic who's down for a Netflix
marathon
no matter your life situation bumble BFF
helps you create the support system you
need expand your crew build a crew find
friends who love the same things you do
shake up your routine with bumble BFF to
use it download bumble on iOS or Android
and switch to bumble BFF mode within the
app then fill out a profile and let your
future besties know what you're all
about
it's super easy to use I actually use
this at VidCon and got to meet a bunch
of people that Lily yeah that listen to
the podcast and and watch the YouTube
videos and so it was really fun they all
got to interact with each other and see
each other on the app too and I think
they've since hopefully have kept the
conversation going wow that's cool yeah
cuz it is really difficult like I'm I
made a lot of friends when I was in
college because just like forced to hang
out everyone's yeah that's one of your
college priorities is find friends right
right but you know now that I am an
adult in my own apartment it's like it's
much more tricky and no one teaches you
how to do it yeah but now you have an
app learn more head to Bumble calm slash
not too deep that's bumble calm slash
not too deep squeezing in time for your
family work and hitting the gym feels
impossible so something's got to give
and it's probably the gym but guess what
body boss can help unlock your dream
body with the great 12 week body boss
workout program do it at home in just 24
minutes a day three days a week you guys
know me I love being in my house I'm
Jim's kind of freaked me out because I'm
just the social aspect of it all the
dynamics that happen there but this you
can do at home that's less than 90
minutes a week with no equipment no
subscription thanks to the hashtag boss
effect or excess post-exercise oxygen
consumption you burn fat long after your
workout plus with the caring pro coaches
and a free Facebook group of supportive
kick-ass women you are never alone so
try body boss with a special offer just
for our listeners and get 25% off the
fitness guide at body boss comm such
grace order now and get free shipping
any money back guarantee this is the
best deal ever get body boss for 25% off
at body boss comm / Gray's 12 weeks from
now you'll thank yourself for starting
that's body boss calm / grace
okay we're gonna get into some internet
questions before we do I'm gonna ask you
the two questions I ask every guest that
is on the podcast and the first is who
alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at Oh cold
spaghetti like I'm offended by this it's
up for interpretation mmm
cold spaghetti mm-hmm
I don't know why the first thing that
came up was Cleopatra I have no idea
that we haven't had that yet don't even
know why I would be fascinated to see
how that went
maybe what she would do maybe that's why
I'm curious yeah I feel like that could
go in either direction either like
totally flattered or completely pissed
off yes so maybe she'll like the taste
of it
yeah it would be an exotic food to her
okay the other question asked every
guest is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or like close call but
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so for example mine
is college jogging front lawn okay
pants shooting our close call we're like
pissing your pants just sort of bathroom
emergency college campus ceramic turtle
sandbox whoa what was Syracuse's campus
life well no follow-up question but that
paints a very bizarre picture okay let's
get into these Internet questions some
wants to know how did you decide the
number of A's in your Twitter handle
because your Twitter handle is lyric
said wha you know I think that I did
like a comedy rule of threes thing okay
it's almost like it can't be to it or
for I must be three yeah I think that's
great
have you tried to change it to your name
or you just don't it doesn't even matter
you know what I think that when I first
got on Twitter I think someone had lyric
Louis I like something like that I was
like you were not the real one it is me
but I feel like Papa NBC can get that
changed for you that's true papa
NBC if you're listening please enjoy so
I haven't
I might do it now though yeah someone to
know have you ever been in a teacher's
lounge like a real one mm-hmm yes yeah
mm-hmm I teach at The Groundlings I also
teach improv so we have a very swanky
teacher's lounge from time to time oh
very cool
have you no because of being doing an AP
bio do you look at high school any
differently oh yeah really
teachers go to I mean like there I hope
this and this isn't spilling any tea
like this is a fact about like teachers
I guess but in interviews Michael Bryan
some teachers say like they never go to
the bathroom so a lot of them have like
UTIs Oh Dan because they like and I was
like I never thought about it but I'm
like you know I never saw my teachers
use the matter when would they have a
chance they don't until they're off
period and so like it's something weird
that I think back and I'm like oh my god
like we were just being pure monsters
yeah and these teachers were like did
not leave their post until they had a
free hour I've never thought about it
like that before we don't think of them
as like people right no that's not
mm-hmm did you have a teacher growing up
that or like a favorite teacher or one
that like truly like affected you or
like helped shape who you are oh I had
to one I helped shape her name was Jan
Mandel and she was my theatre teacher in
high school and she was one that gave
like the Fleck really encouraged your
own creativity your mind writing for
yourself and like I know early start on
like point of view and like what you
think is funny and like that's awesome
so she did that in high school which was
great and then I had this other lady I'm
in seventh grade her name was mr.
Fetterman and she's taught at Highland
Park junior high my high school was
saying potential fame y'all listening
but a misfit er man taught Spanish but
she was this tiny woman she wasn't had
to be like for eighth or like five feet
at the most so she would get up on a
desk and teach us like our directions
and everything and she taught us the
alphabet but with sign language Oh
also and it was so like it just she was
so excited to teach that I like took
Spanish for a while in college too but
she was the main one that I was like you
make languages cool yeah so Miss fair -
ma'am oh that's very cool I kind of
looked like Miss Frizzle wait she stood
on her own destiny she was tiny so she
would stand above us and go a la derecha
he's scared whatever we like we're so in
tune as we could see so fun but yeah a
teacher that has enthusiasm is
infectious
yeah and it sticks with you obviously
mm-hmm that's so cool
do you speak a lot of Spanish now you
know I think I speak a lot of Spanglish
time to time but I love the language
it's very cool I wish I spoke any other
language um so let's know your best and
worst or best and least favorite curse
word ooh yeah um oh okay my best one
oh I feel like I really like [ __ ] [ __ ]
is like a fine like it's still light
enough like I say it's um but friends
I'm like ooh [ __ ] so to me it still is
that kind of fun yeah that is heavy my
least one I was like I feel like my
least one is probably it's a tie between
even though I feel like it's kind of a
curse word you see my whisper no I'm
with you though yeah I I just when I
don't you know I curse a decent amount
of my life colloquially but and that's
when I'm like I'm not so in that or
[ __ ] like I know yeah what else was
another one that aggressive it's very
good where it's not fun right yeah I
like the fun yeah
kelan Cox tweeted what are your favorite
true crimes podcast I meant to text you
today but this feels like a reasonable
way to ask you to kallen what a way to
get yourself onto a podcast
have you had to rank like your top three
at the moment cuz I know it probably
shifts and changes at the moment it
would be I would say true crime junkie
okay no crime junkie true crime obsessed
and dr. death oh okay tied with sport
and scale okay I'm one of those people
yeah we got to have them all
it can count any of them this one might
be hard unless it sticks out to you
someone to know what's the most
interesting thing you saw or read this
week oh um the most interesting thing
that I saw a read this week it's tough
I'm trying to think of what my answer
would be the most interesting thing I
saw well the most interesting I saw
right before I came here it's fresh in
my mind was that we're now getting
presidential text so that's very yeah I
haven't even looked completely into this
just got one today we got once a day and
so that's why was that probably on your
phone yeah what so that'll be the alert
one yeah yeah yeah what does that mean
it's like Trump can just text us now
which is very interesting I was like I
did not know this was happening and I
was like what yeah it looked like an
Amber Alert that's kind of what I wrote
it off at but in everyone got it like Oh
at the same time so like all of our
phones went off at the same time I don't
like yes very interesting stately so I
was like I need to read up on whatever
has happened that's the same thing he
just happened today jeez I mean and
that's like I've already am paranoid
that we're being looked at and listening
to like 24/7 and so now they're just
actively presenting themselves inside of
our phones yeah yeah someone's know
what's the most ridiculous thing someone
tricked you into doing or believing no
one tricked me into it but I kind of
tricked myself and my mom snapped me out
of it that I used to think the onion was
a real newspaper I didn't know and so I
this was back in like cut me some slack
please don't come for me anyway this is
back in like oh six oh seven where I
don't know I'd never heard of it and so
I was teaching us summer camp for the
Science Museum huh and I was on break
and it was like a full ream of them like
it look like a regular newspaper stand
side grabs what did I just I had never
heard of it so I started reading and I
would never forget because it was the
title of it was like man knows his son
is gay he looks he grabs that glitter
and moves his butt like the talk of the
town and they were just up and I read
the article but I got
so offended like I got mad I was like
crying I got like two years I was like
this poor child I call my mom at work
and I was like did you say that like I'm
sorry she was like the onion is fake and
I was like what no I don't know because
I don't know this was after I graduated
from Syracuse I don't know how I missed
sure the onion like in college when I
feel like other people must have known
that's so funny
but I was really offended cuz I was like
this poor child
offended so much to the way that you
called your mom I was like I was like
really mad cuz I was like this baby is a
baby let him explore himself I know
sometimes I look quickly cuz I follow
them on Twitter and I like browse
through really quickly and see a
headline and be like wait a minute what
you have to check myself that it's
tweeting it I'm supposed to know what is
your go-to snack oh this is a hard one
cuz I love a good snack I don't know if
I have one goats who I love cheez-its
oh really like the original cheese's
uh-huh but I'm also into like pickles
okay are you pregnant no I think like I
don't cuz I don't know if I have a
really good if you could let's say
hypothetically you got to create your
ideal craft services on set what would
you put on there I would have Nacho
Cheese Doritos oh dang yes cheez-its
okay some fruits like some have a
grapefruit yogurt I love yogurt what
else would I have though meats yeah
protein you know some protein maybe some
you know some you know some salmon yeah
some you know beef Jerky's pepperonis
[Laughter]
chicken Fritta chickens so basically
just the entire grocery store
small grocery store but the Trader Joe's
Dorito like tortilla chips cuz those are
when I don't hate on me for this Dorito
when I say the Trader Joe's nacho ones
are in sane and they're gluten-free
haven't even tried them oh now I know
get on them thank you for that nah so
that's actually my go-to snack Trader
Joe's nacho cheese tortilla chips that
sounds amazing
okay we have one final question for you
and someone's to know what would you do
if dinosaurs ran amok in LA oh I would
be inside of my apartment I mean I enjoy
them from a distance you know I think
that they're fascinating beautiful
creatures but I'm like I make no
mistakes I like my life I rub elbows in
the dinosaur I'm not trying to get tore
up from the floor up extremely fair
answer like I I wouldn't be curious
I would I would not eat I wouldn't need
to do anything but be in my apartment on
the third floor unless they figure out
elevators then I'm good I guess if it's
a Rex I have an issue the the sauropods
and the you know your um your plant
eaters I'd be about them but the meat
eaters oh no somebody else can please
handle them I think that's a very very
fair answer lyric thank you so much for
being here thank you for having me
before you go completely the curious
weird random singular a fortune cookie
that was over on that table is for you
as a gift for being on the podcast and
welcome you open it and read the fortune
that's inside let me see now I have to
eat the whole cookie you don't have to
that's not a requirement I think that's
it oh oh
fairly long this is a formal shout out
to made well on my personal behalf for
them to sponsor a shopping spree for you
as a promoter for whatever they can make
something up now we wait yes so so your
love made well I love me well should
this
and when did this happen surely the
clothes are made well okay
truly I got into them I want to say like
a year ago not very long ago but I all
my girlfriend's like I'd be like that
top is so cute that button-up is great
where you get that from maybe like made
well and I'm like what is this magical
place went there in the jeans or what
really got me because I feel like a lot
of people don't make jeans for women's
bodies hmm hold it in when I've had a
couple drinks and I feel like made well
does that but there closes they fit
really good like every type of body
they're made well i how you're not
sponsored by made well blows my mind at
this but I know but trust me I will be
there at their store opening on Ventura
on October 16th 6:00 to 8:00 p.m. for
snacks and a free tote with a purchase
which I will be planning on making and
so at that time me and made walking
discuss it but I I'm I'm about their
life that's so hard
that's incredible I accept this fortune
that made well well I mean we put it out
we're manifesting it for you thank you
lyric where can people find you online
where they where can they see you on
stage where can they watch you on TV
online you can catch me at lyric dee
Lewis on the gram oh Lord
small burp you know I'm yes but lyric
dee Lewis on Instagram I talk back I
love to do a fun story it's great you
know give me suggestions of new flavors
of Lucroy to try it will do it and also
on Twitter lyrics say wow with three A's
for the comedic timing of it all I will
try to talk back I will talk back more
on the gram but I will eventually holla
back at you on Twitter and just catch me
in the streets you know I like cher to
Joe's and made well make sure you go
check her out and uh ap bio next year
get ready
February please be ready mark your
calendars on to your buzz or not we'll
see you guys next episode of not too
deep good bye bye too deep tody ot not
too deep as a production of grace Helbig
incorporated a producer and directed by
Jay
very producer and editor melissa demons
writing by Diane King post production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]